schauen wir nach deutschland schießerei
im hamburger stadtteil hohenfelde in
einer shisha bar ist in der nacht zu
donnerstag ein 27 jähriger erschossen
wurden gegen 23 uhr alarmierten zeugen
die einsatzkräfte und meldeten diese
schüsse sie berichteten dass zwei täter
die bar betreten hatten und gezielt auf
das opfer zu bestimmt waren anschließend
hatte einer von ihnen seine waffe auf
den 27 jährigen gerichtet und mehrmals
abgedrückt bevor beide dann die flucht
retter kämpften vor ort um das leben des
mannes und begann umgehend mit der
reanimation
anschließend brachten sie ihn in ein
krankenhaus wo er noch in der nacht
seinen schweren verletzungen erlag
unklar ob es eine gezielte hinrichtung
war die polizei ist auf der suche nach
zeugen die täter sind zwischen 1 70 und
1 meter 80 groß trugen zum zeitpunkt des
angriffs schwarze trainingsjacken dunkle
hosen schwarze mützen und corona mas
[Musik]